[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody
happy
monday
uh yeah sheila ann says did i hear anne
rice just died yes she did that's why we
did this that's why we decided to do
queen of the damned because i was kind
of like well i feel like they haven't
really made a lot of uh adaptations of
anne rice's stuff amazingly even though
she's written like a zillion books and
we'd already done the good one interview
with the vampire yeah and uh queen of
the damned i was sitting there going i
could have sworn that i saw this movie
and it just didn't make any impression
at all or i didn't like it and but then
we were watching again i'm like maybe i
didn't see this movie yeah like maybe
i've just seen clips of it that other
people like talked about because it was
a lot of [ __ ] that i just totally didn't
remember either that or it just
completely didn't make an impression
what are you doing back there but
beating up on some [ __ ] yeah okay but i
was just like really interested to
re-watch it and i don't know that's just
what i thought of because i said well
we've already done an interview with the
vampire and they haven't really done any
other
adaptations of her stuff
so since she just passed away
i was like maybe we should have another
look at queen of the damned and see how
we feel about that uh so it was a lot
better than i remembered it
it well like i said i can't remember it
but it's still not really a good movie
though i mean i have to say i think
i think what they did was uh they just
tried to put
too much into one movie
uh the book
is kind of long and a lot happens in the
book it's it's kind of like dune it's
not really all that movable
and anne rice's writing is not real well
conducive not really conducive to a
movie she jumps around a lot
um
but
hold on one second
yeah louie said i saw this one in the
theaters it's okay
yeah it's not terrible
it's just
it's kind of sad because i feel like it
was sort of like a missed opportunity
more than anything
um
because what ended up happening with it
is that so warner brothers
uh had the rights like they took over
lorimar so they got the rights to a
bunch of her stuff like all the vampire
chronicles and the mayfair witches so
they got uh all the rights to her stuff
back in 1998 i think
and so obviously they had done interview
with the vampire uh you know laura mara
done in 1994 and that was actually like
a really big success like critically and
with audiences
so uh but the rights were going to
revert to her
uh in 2000
so basically what warner brothers had to
do they're like well if we want to do
something with these properties we have
to get something into production before
2000
or she'll get the rights back
and you know we'll have to like
repurchase them or renegotiate or
whatever and they didn't want to do that
so it almost seemed like they were like
well you know what can we
throw together
really quick that we can get into
production before the rights revert to
her
uh is essentially what they were doing
yeah so it wasn't um
so to me it just it seemed a little
half-assed and i'm i'm not saying that
an adaptation of them couldn't be done
but
i'm really not sure that this was the
way to go about it it's been better as a
mini-series
well yeah and i think even anne rice
like was was wanting to go in that
direction too i mean even back then
because this there's i mean it's a lot
these are three very very very long
books
um a lot of [ __ ] goes on it spans
centuries and centuries and trying to
cram i mean trying to cram one long book
into a movie is bad enough but then
trying to cram sort of like two of them
in there but honestly it's really weird
because trying to cram two books into
one movie but then leaving out like 80
of each book is just a really strange
decision and then making stuff up
that too
um in
in this version of the tale
this stop was made by marius who is one
of the characters in the book
who's another vampire
but the start in the books the stock
wasn't made by marius he's made by
another guy called magnus he was a damn
sorcerer long time ago
an old guy who dug up a damn
half dead starving vampire and drank its
blood he turned himself into a vampire
and he wasn't a success he wasn't a
successful vampire
because he was too old when he was made
he didn't have teeth hardly
so once he figured out how to be a
vampire he just grabbed the prettiest
boy he liked and turned him into a
vampire and killed himself
made a replacement and that was the stop
the stop was just made and he didn't
even really know who made him he just
said the only he told him he had him up
in a castle gave him a pad you know it
was totally secure behind blocks
and the only he told him was the only
thing you need to know is that you must
drink blood you cannot go into the
sunlight and you can be destroyed by
fire and you can't be beheaded and then
he goes bye peace out bye
with a couple of sticks good luck yeah
we'll see and and i saw like another
review that actually pointed this out
quite succinctly was like by changing
that aspect because in this movie queen
of the damned which as i said uh has
elements of both the vampire lestat and
queen damned they do go a little bit
into lestat's backstory like how he was
made but they switched it to another
character marius who was a bigger
character in the book
but marius also not only makes him but
also like gives him vampire pointers and
is like his mentor
and i think that one of the interesting
things about lestat's character in the
book is that he didn't have that he had
to figure everything out by himself he
just got like you know turned into a
vampire by this dude that just like
you know like just split and he just
like left him on it like abandoned him
essentially yeah and and it's
the book and kind of hints that
magnus did that because he didn't like
the other vampires so he was just
starting a vampire off from scratch
yeah not to be like the other ones
well i guess it worked yeah
the books are real good uh you know if
you guys want to read a good we've never
read the vampire chronicles read them
they're good
um
now this movie is this movie good
it's okay
it's okay it is not the book
it's got a good soundtrack especially
for the time kind of goth inspired metal
well it's new metal new battles what it
is um
which
there's some marilyn manson in it
some of the costumes of the goth
characters in there that pretty accurate
some of that stuff they still kind of
wear today
um
it does kind of
look like the goth scene at certain
points in certain parts of the story
um
it is kind of a time capsule though and
in other ways
it's it's interesting movie i like it i
was kind of thinking like some of it's
okay some of it's kind of cringy yeah um
and then i was like what and then i was
thinking about it like earlier today i
was like that movie is almost kind of
like hot topic throughout all over it is
it is i mean big time it's very me like
late 90s early 2000s hot topic just
threw up all over this movie
it's kind of like what happens when the
mainstream gets a hold of a subculture
and tries to bring it [ __ ] into the
into the into the mainstream it's going
to look like a hot topic ad
it's yeah that's pretty much what it
looked like um it was not quite seedy
and down to earth like the real goth
scene was
well and another thing too is that the
parts of the vampire lestat that they
used which was essentially the framing
story
of him
waking up like hearing a band playing
and being like hey that sounds pretty
awesome and then he wakes up and decides
to be a rock star as i said vampire stat
that was pretty much just the framing
story there was it was more kind of like
going back in time and like doing other
[ __ ] but that was the framing story but
in the book he wakes up in the 80s yeah
so by jumping it forward to you know
2000 2001 and so having to kind of
change the whole dynamic from
80s rockstar
to
new metal
person yeah um i'm not sure it really
translated all that well i don't know if
translated well was the word but it's
just it gives a totally different like
vibe or totally different feeling to it
another thing that didn't translate well
is that there's a big fight scene that
happens in the book and it happens at a
rock concert
that works in a book but when you
actually see that
portrayed in a film it looks it just it
doesn't look real it looks like it was
very silly real silly well and i think i
was the goths are in the damn crowd
watching this fight between vampires
happen and they just think it's part of
the show
and
it's just
you're like come on no way and and it's
just like this these people are
centuries these guys are
they're old you know i mean they've been
around for centuries and they're worried
about rock music and [ __ ] or at least
lestat is i don't think he really would
would have given a [ __ ] with with the
background of their stories but you know
suzanne rice talking
this is her this is her fantasy guys
these [ __ ] vampires
well i couldn't remember because it's
been a long time since i read the book
so i actually just went through and read
like quick plot synopsis so i could
remember like what had been left out um
a [ __ ] ton also i think i've mentioned
it before but dominic noble has a really
good channel and he did
a book to movie adaptation on queen of
the damned and he and all the [ __ ] that
was left out is just alarming there's
like tons and tons of huge masses of
plot points like numbers of characters
things happened is wrong too but what i
was going to say was that
i think um that
even though the attack by the vampires
happens on stage in the movie i think it
did happen at a concert in the book but
i think it happened while he was on the
way out i don't think it happened like
in front of a crowd please correct me if
i'm wrong
because it's been so long since i've
read it but i don't think it happened
the way it happens in the movie because
in the movie it looks very goofy yeah um
you know what i mean it's it's just kind
of a very very goofy scene and then you
know akasha the queen of the damned like
comes in and like
yeah and like what whisks him away like
she's played by uh aaliyah
yeah a singer who got killed i think in
a car wreck plane crash it was a plane
crash it was her they were they were
actually flying to or from the bahamas
like that she had just shot a video
she had great in this too she looks
great in it she does a good job with
what do what the material she was given
you know
but uh is that the way i imagined akasha
from the book kinda
yeah yeah i will say that stewart
townsend who plays lestat in this uh
he's an irish actor
he
looks more like what i pictured when i
read the book yeah um a little bit more
but
he doesn't he's not as
if and i can't believe he's fluid i
can't believe i'm saying this yeah but
he's not as charismatic as tom cruise
nope i'm telling you man i [ __ ]
defend cruz i defend tom when tom does a
good [ __ ] job on a damn movie
i think tom even though he was way too
old for the for the role of lestat
lestat was actually supposed to be 16 or
17. yeah he was like he was like a late
teenager when he got turned into a into
a vampire
but still lestat [ __ ] characterized
[ __ ] excuse me um tom actually
brought lestat to life lestat was an
arrogant [ __ ] prick all right but he
was charismatic he was likable and he
was always also kind of vulnerable but
he he hit it
and and tom nailed it i think tom did a
good job he did actually you nailed it
and another thing
is that lestat was real easy around
mortal women they you know and tom comes
across that way in that movie this dude
not so much he almost feels like he's
uncomfortable around these girls that he
that they're getting ready to suck his
that's well that's kind of another thing
i wanted to address too because i kind
of feel like i mean
uh i see i saw a couple of the reviews
of this that were like this movie
essentially straight washes
the character because in the books
that was a homoerotic
feast for you know what i mean uh i mean
lestat was not portrayed as gay but he
was pretty much all his great loves were
men
and so there was a lot of like hot man
on man action and in this it seemed like
they took great pains
to make lestat really straight they even
made a romance between him and jesse the
chick from the talamasco which doesn't
happen in the book no they don't even
hardly know each other in the book
that's two kind of different timelines
you do kind of have to straighten it out
though
the stat wasn't gay per se he was a
vampire no but i'm just saying he didn't
have sex yeah i know that but i'm just
saying
i'm just saying that there was a lot of
you know kind of gay subtext not even
subtext text in the books and they did
it in interview with the vampire the
movie too
um so i just it just seemed very odd to
me that they went out of their way
to make him like super straight in this
movie which it was just very strange in
the books
vampires could not have sex they just
didn't have any biological functions
they didn't eat they didn't they didn't
piss or [ __ ] or anything they didn't it
was just pure drinking blood drinking
blood was their version of sex
but all their loves were platonic and
kind of romantic
and
they were all [ __ ] romantically all
into each other but they didn't
have sex it was just because they were a
new species they weren't human beings
they were [ __ ] ghosts basically
they're poltergeists
that which that's that's that's a wild
spirit well you find that out later find
out in lasher they're all kind of
infested with a single poltergeist
i hate what happened
what's that i hate when that happens
yeah
and and it get it gave them um
psychic abilities and they could do
stuff and a bunch of [ __ ] happens in out
of order in the movie like
akasha
wakes up because she hears the stop
playing the violin in front of her but
that's not how i remembered it she woke
up because she heard him playing on the
radio
because they could hear radio waves see
oh maybe i can't i can't remember they
didn't they could be laying in the damn
grave
i thought it was violin but maybe i like
i said it's been such a long time i
thought she heard him on the radio if i
remember correctly because they could be
laying in a tomb sleeping for centuries
but they could hear what was going on
around him like in their subconscious it
was kind of like a dream
and lestat was down in there for what
he spent the 1700s all the way into the
1980s just laying in a damn grave kind
of sleeping and listening to the radio
yeah and listening to all the radio
bands
but they could also kind of go out of
body in a certain way and do weird
things like call people who wanted to
commit suicide to him and then they'd
drink them and
they could [ __ ] feel a serial killer
or a murderer and go out and get that
guy
there's all kinds of [ __ ] they could do
because they were kind of in tune with a
kind of a cosmic unconscious or kind of
like a spiritual psychic internet they
could detect each other and stuff we can
feel the force i guess
but it it's so some of the stuff is out
of order uh it didn't happen the way it
did in the book and i was going to say
too that by moving the movie queen of
the damned to
the contemporary time period moving it
to the early 2000s
you're also [ __ ] up the timeline
because
uh you know interview with the vampire
1994 obviously um which the part that
where he was being interviewed did take
place in 1994 and lestat was awake
whereas in queen of the damned he says
oh i just woke up when i heard this band
in presumably 2001 or 2002
where he was supposed to still be asleep
so it doesn't even uh it doesn't even
track with the earlier movie he should
have still been sleeping
i think that they i know they probably
didn't have the budget um but they
should have done it the way the book was
where he woke up in the 1980s i think if
they were making it now they would
totally do that um but
for whatever reason i guess because they
wanted like
a bunch of new metal because that's what
was the thing although i kind of feel
like new metal was a little bit on its
way out at that time like maybe like
maybe on the decline
i think that was the heidi of it because
like the dude from corn did his singing
voice for this movie
and there was like some other [ __ ] there
was like kidney thieves was in there and
um
disturbed i liked this mother [ __ ] i
liked the music it was it was it was
good i uh
um i had it i think no what was it i had
the movie and the movie i had the dvd
for a while the dvd had all the videos
on it yeah i think and you could you
could watch them
and uh some of the stuff is like a
cabinet of dr caligari style bajau style
music videos i did like that yeah that's
that was the best part of him pretending
he's doing music videos pretending that
he's the stop it's supposed to be like
you're watching lestat's videos
if i remember in the book
akasha had heard on the radio while she
was in her damn trance
this an idea that a vampire was now
coming out into public
which was a big big no-no the no-no to
all the other vampires which was kind of
a big plot point in this movie but
akasha woke up
because that's the way she lived her
life and she was like the mother of all
the vampires so she her her deal was
that she want to wake up kill all the
other vampires that [ __ ] were she she
called him cowards i guess
and then take over the entire planet and
it would just be her and lestat and then
humanity would just basically be cows be
food for them they were going to
overthrow all the damn governments and
destroy technology even though i don't
know how much she knew what she was
talking about she showed up with a house
and i don't understand how she that bet
she couldn't even know what an atm was i
don't know who she got to get the house
she's a vampire she's magic she just
well
[Laughter]
originally you know they were trying to
give the movie the benefit
in the books they usually just turned
the owner of a house into a vampire
moved in
that's how they stole the house well see
i assumed because when we were watching
this last night and it's like the whole
scene with her and lestat in the in the
bathtub with all the rose petals or
whatever and you were like where did she
get that house from and i was thinking
oh maybe she just like found a house i
was like hey i like this one and just
killed the people that
just hate the people on the island or
burned them up because her thing
aaliyah's thing or queen of the damn
thing akasha rather she could just kind
of go like that and like you'd [ __ ]
spontaneously combust if you were a weak
vampire yeah well she could do that to
humans too right uh no just vampires i
think
that she would she could i guess like
you can throw him but well yeah just
waved her hand on a vampire that turned
into dust unless they could fight it
unless he could fight it remember
because the stop fought fought it back
but he had a whole lot of her blood that
he drank
yeah well because she offered it to him
when he when he went down there and woke
her up with the violin yeah because
there are statues you know i don't know
because i don't know like it's not
really explained in the movie
one thing that i said i think that after
we watched the movie i was like if you
had not
read the books you wouldn't understand
this movie would be incomprehensible
well largely incomprehensible because
and honestly the two books like i said
in the really long
this probably uses
10 to 20 of the vampire lestat mostly
the framing story about him being a rock
star and then it uses some of the stuff
wait was the stuff about jesse and the
talamasca was that in vampire lestat or
queen of the damned i think it was in
vampire the st that's the thing so i
can't remember and this book kind of
bleeds over it from other books this is
more than one book yeah it's two books
that's what i just said yeah but yes and
queen of the damned was about was more
about akasha and what was the king's
name and kill and kill yes
something like that like so a bunch of
that took place in ancient egypt and was
kind of talking about her [ __ ] and how
that happened and how they ended up
being like these just these statues that
marius was watching over
um like down in this
tomb or whatever so that kind of went
into that whereas this story takes place
entirely
in the modern day or the contemporary
time when the movie was made and they
don't really they just do a couple of
flashbacks like i said to lestat being
made
by a completely different person
um doesn't really go and another thing
that's weird is that they like david
talbot is in the movie like from the
talamasca
and he's cut he's young in the it's like
i thought he was an old man he was an
old man right
uh yeah he's an old man i thought he was
an old man and so 70s so the whole time
like so i'm watching like the talamaska
scenes and jesse calls him david i'm
like wait a second that's not david
david's an old dude i'm like this is
like a young guy like maybe in his late
30s or something so i thought that was a
little weird and there's like a whole
bunch of characters
that
are not in there um and then there are
characters that are in there but you
wouldn't know who they were unless you
looked at the credits like armand is in
there but you wouldn't know it was
armand because he's never referred to as
armand he's like in that one scene at
the end like with all those with uh
maharat and all them yeah um yeah that's
another thing is that they just can't
cover the scope of the books every damn
vampire in this [ __ ] movie
has got a long back story when you're
reading about it you know everything
about and everything that happened in
the past and who they were and our mom
had his whole his own book too right
yeah yeah yeah she did one called the
vampire i remember that yeah some had
their own books that's right
i had forgotten all about them they're
all good they're all pretty good i think
i read all of them over and i've read
all the mayfair witches ones too i think
over time like i don't remember a lot of
the lore and stuff because it's been a
long time since i've read them
but
best one was uh
interview the vampire
uh
[ __ ] uh
vampire lestat queen of the damned
mem knocked the devil was good
yeah i think i got that over there and i
think uh what was the other one
last year
those are the main ones lasher was the
one about the poltergeist like how
vampires came into existence
yeah
i don't remember i remember i read vamp
the vampire armand um
and i liked that one i didn't like any
of them as much as i liked the first
three yeah and i mean of the first three
interview with the vampire and vampires
thought were my favorite once it started
going
into queen of the damned and started
going into that stuff i started kind of
losing interest but i still read them
um
i mean those first two were just so good
once it started being about characters
other than lestat and louis i was just
kind of like meh and it wasn't like
louie wasn't even in this movie
no like lestat did not mention him
um
he was not referred to which i thought
was a little strange yeah because in the
real in the book he was like all over it
yeah and that's what i've been showing
up and stuff there's a bunch of stuff
well there was like well i mean lestat
and louis had like a really like uh you
know very close complicated relationship
for a very very long time so it seemed
really weird that he wouldn't at least
like refer to him
you know what i'm saying um
but yeah so there were a lot of
characters because like i said there's
there's a really good video where he
points out like all the stuff that was
left out but they leave out
like just so many characters and just so
many plot points it's just it's crazy
scott never mentions claudia
yeah
and that's what i thought was a little
girl they made into the empire she got
burned up by some other badass vampires
that were [ __ ]
in a damn
french [ __ ] acting troupe that was
some weird [ __ ] that happened there
because she was too little you weren't
supposed to be making little kids
yeah and even in the movie interview
with the vampire and and that's what's
weird it's like even if you were kind of
shooting for this movie like i said it
seemed like warner brothers just made
this so they could retain the rights
yeah you know what i'm saying right
because they didn't want the rights
going back to her
um
so it seemed like they kind of
half-assed it a little bit
and
but it but it doesn't even it's not even
in continuity with the 1994 movie like
it's it doesn't bring up louie it
doesn't bring up claudia it doesn't
bring up any of that stuff and claudia
she was she died at the end of interview
with the vampire spoiler alert but uh
she she got killed but i think her ghost
like turns up and goes in vampire lestat
right right she's mentioned all the
times i think her ghost turns up i
thought it did something like that or
they think they see her ghost just
that's a good thing about the series is
that things would be mentioned and never
really
resolved like uh
and i think it was i think it was uh
vampire lestat
when he was a young vampire back in the
honky motherland
he thought he was the only vampire one
time in his mind he heard that there was
some kind of
some kind of a creature that he thought
was a vampire when he ran over there to
go see what it was it was miles away out
in the forest
when he when he found it it was just
walking along a mindless corpse he
destroyed it never answered what that
was
and like he found a zombie yeah i guess
or a vampire that was so old it was
but no it must have been a zombie
but it was never answered what that was
you remember you don't remember that
part do you
i sort of do yeah he he thought that he
might have been the only vampire like he
like he was he thought that's the way a
vampire most vampires might as might
have been but what he described was a
zombie
um a bunch of weird [ __ ] happens in the
books they're good though the books are
good
uh much better than this uh although
look
i remember this thing looking really
cheap
uh the version we saw maybe i don't know
if it was remastered it was free we saw
it on tubey yeah
um it's worth watching it looked a lot
better than i remembered it the cgi was
not as annoying as i remembered it
although dermott just said queen of the
damned was full of cgi which was all the
rage back then but which now dates the
movie bit like the underworld movies
yeah i didn't love the vampire flying
yeah the fact that didn't really look
that yeah they flew in the book though
they levitated some of them could fly
how strong they were vampire power yeah
vampire powers you're a new vampire you
couldn't fly that was like that was like
some [ __ ] that you got like after you
were around you had to drink a lot of
damn blood and had to be yeah
um now here's another thing is that they
they didn't
they never explained why
why akasha and her king were statues and
it was
the book the book explains it yeah
if you
got old enough and drank enough blood
you would eventually just start to get
real solid and hard and you'd [ __ ]
start pulling away from reality you'd
kind of go into an out-of-body type
state
and the vampire would kind of to protect
itself
grow a hard
skin that was as hard as rock a human
couldn't do anything to it
and it would just be frozen there but
they were kind of like in and out of
body state like a meditative state and
they were kind of like a suspended
animation they could stay like that for
centuries yeah because they were like
thousands of years old they were
thousands years old because weren't they
like 3000 years old or something
ridiculous like it's kind of like a
hibernation period that they could go in
and um
the stop was able to bite through her
and get and steal a bunch of her blood
he got real strong but she let him do it
yeah
she probably could have hardened herself
up there so he couldn't bite through her
but he bit through her wrist and [ __ ]
got real because she was uh enchanted
with him yeah
and then she softened back up into a
[ __ ]
woman-type body
and her outfit's [ __ ] fantastic man
she actually really does look really her
back they show her from the back of that
outfit and her back is like [ __ ]
incredibly [ __ ] hourglass shaped real
long and she's got the dab the way they
had their little cuffs and the sleeves
and everything
only like 120 pound woman could wear
that costume and look great at it i mean
she's really the best thing about this
movie and i kind of wish the movie had
been more about her yeah they needed a
little bit more her she actually was i
don't want to say i don't want to
i kind of liked her better than lestat i
did too yeah well she was certainly more
charismatic and a lot more interesting
yeah and honestly if the movie was
called queen of the damned i mean she's
the queen of damn it should have been
about her because the book the queen of
the damned like i said most of it's set
in ancient egypt and it's about her
um you know but this was mostly about
lestat oh and by the way like in it
takes like an hour before she even shows
up really yeah uh and they put the other
talamaska stuff in there with the stuff
with jesse and the stuff with jessie was
like not that interesting and like i
said they they
made this whole like romance plot
between lestat and jesse which totally
did not happen in the book
they barely knew each other i think he
only met her like once or twice yeah and
so i thought that was a little weird
louis says amc is doing a vampire
chronicles series eight episodes in
2022. oh that's gonna be good so next
year we'll see yeah i thought i had
heard something about theaters no no amc
probably the the channel okay the cable
channel american movie classics
hopefully it'll be good
i mean
to be honest with you this isn't a
terrible movie but i can't see how it
could be worse than this
i mean if you had people that were
really
cared about it and actually wanted to
get across
um you know how much because as i said
this is a huge
sprawling story with lots and lots and
lots of characters yeah they tried to do
it all in one shot
in one movie and it's just kind of like
they tried with the first dune to try to
do it all in one shot and it's just not
possible yeah like why would you even
think that you could do that and you're
gonna have to swap a lot of [ __ ] around
to make
to make a the story movieable
because the books kind of meander when
you're actually reading it but you enjoy
the [ __ ] path that that rice has
taken you through it's not a direct path
you can tell she's kind of making it up
as she's going along you can tell she
kind of forgets certain
things like she starts going in one
direction then she says that [ __ ] i'm
going to the other end that's about that
she's just writing you know and
and it's uh it has a real um
um
not digital uh [ __ ] analog feel to it
it's it's very conducive to like fantasy
you're reading it well it's kind of like
episodic more than
just one big long like compelling
narrative it's just kind of goes off in
a lot of sprawling directions you know
like a like big epic stories do
and trying to cram
two books worth of that into one movie
it just seemed like a fool's errand yeah
now
i wouldn't say that this was straight
washed
the stat and all the other vampires
liked women too they didn't
differentiate between male or females
they did but i just thought it was
really weird how this movie really
seemed not to want to mention i didn't
want to mention that he got fascinated
with men too and the whole the whole
scene where he takes where he takes that
violin from that gypsy woman or whatever
um that was a man in the books that
wasn't a woman yeah um so
so why they changed that i'm not really
sure but uh but they did change a lot of
stuff from the book that a vampire would
just see a human being and start getting
fascinated with them they just thought
they were like another species
and they would just start thinking about
who they were in their lives and want to
drink their [ __ ] blood and would kind
of fall in love with them but then kill
them it was a weird thing or sometimes
they'd hate them and kill them just
depending on who it was
some vampires would they could kind of
read minds or read souls you know they
could tell what kind of person you were
they could seize parts of your past
and they could tell what you were
thinking
so some some vampires hunted out killers
that's what they liked they liked to eat
those
some of them liked real pure people and
children and [ __ ] just depending on who
they were
so and and
they were kind of
didn't matter if they were male or
female they kind of got into it in a
different way
they didn't have sex though there was no
and i'm not even sure there was love i
think yeah but it was what didn't have
to do with
didn't have anything to do with
anybody's gender
right well but they had like sort of
human-esque emotions i mean romantic
about [ __ ] well and i mean look at you
know and they even put this in the movie
interview with the vampire look how uh
lestat and louie became parents to
claudia who in the books i don't know if
you guys knew this in the movie it was
she was you know maybe 12 years old in
the book she's six yeah she's a lot
smaller so uh which i'm kind of glad
they didn't put that in the movie
because that would have been a little
creepy it's a little bitty kristen dunst
and she did a great job in that movie
did a great job she was great in that
movie yeah and that is about what that
character was like in the book yeah but
much much much much younger but like i
said that would have been
yeah she was eating people well i could
can you imagine being a six-year-old
girl yeah and then you get turned into a
vampire you're not gonna get any older
you don't get to be an adult you don't
get to you know what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do it's like you're you're never
gonna grow up she was collecting girls
yeah as dolls and
hiding them up in the bedroom and [ __ ]
covered but they were all dead yeah and
she couldn't grow up so she wanted to be
a she wanted to be a girl
yeah yeah it's kind of creepy it was the
way it would have been well it was like
tragic yeah um you know which is why the
vampires had that kind of unspoken rule
hey let's not make
vampires you're not really supposed to
make vampires out of like a really like
a kid or a super old person now gotta
give credit where credit's due on on
anne rice and these movies and
everything
traditionally a movie
a vampire tale or a vampire movie a
vampire was just a damn monster the main
characters were the humans and then the
monster appears and then you have to
defeat the monster
it's kind of a boring story when you
think about it
um now in the movie they had bella lagos
bella gosi says some [ __ ] that that
hints
that vampires have a culture and he he
says our strength is that you do not
believe in us
without like oh yeah i never thought
he says a bunch of [ __ ] that
makes you think well what is what how
does a vampire live
you know what's it like from their point
of view
and it just bella just hinted at it
slightly
but in the other movies after that it
was never brought up again
until great movies from the 1970s were
two of them blacula and screen black in
the screen and they were
they they're in the black exploitation
realm but they're real well written
vampire stories they're
black product
and i believe that they they even the
guys that wrote the scripts were black
and rice saw those and from that that's
where she got
the vampire chronicles ideas because
those movies actually
tell the tale from the vampire's point
of view yeah
and like how does damn
mama waldy how does he live
and how does he live with himself he's
kind mama waldy was kind of like
louis in a certain way he was a health
he was a self-hating vampire well he was
turned into one against his will he was
turned into a vampire against his will
and he was turned into a vampire because
he tried to stop slavery and when you
become a vampire you're basically
becoming a slaver
because vampires create slaves that when
they create another vampire they're
basically creating slaves
because they serve him he's a master
vampire so he's being forced into
something he doesn't want to be
and that's a [ __ ] that is anne ricean
to the [ __ ] nth degree that's like
some [ __ ] and rice and rice said yeah
i'm going to go that way
vampires some of them don't want to be
vampires how do they live can because
even in screen black of the scream he
turns
uh a mama wallet he turns this black
dude into a vampire and he goes oh man
look at me and he's all dressed up he
looks in the mirror because man i can't
see myself i can't even see you guys no
come on let's go out because what you
think you're gonna go out and have fun
he goes yeah because no you'll stay
right here
and he goes what do you mean we're not
going to go out and go no you'll go out
there and they will come here and they
will kill us all
and he goes so i can't go outside
because yes you'll obey me i'm your
master because i'm a slave he goes yes
well i mean and
i saw the [ __ ] youtube version rented
and they cut that scene out which that
was one of the things that [ __ ] made
anne rice so great it was like yeah
vampires make slaves out of other people
that's what it is
it's an analogy for slavery
well and that was another uh plot point
that was addressed it was addressed in
the movie too at queen of the damned is
that uh the vampires were you know they
wanted to
keep in the shadows obviously so they
could have this sort of like demi monde
if you want to call it that uh you know
where people wouldn't come and like
[ __ ] burn them up or cut their heads
off or whatever and lestat
very very uh you know blatantly
uh kind of just spit in the face of that
he's like i'm gonna be a world famous
rock star i'm gonna tell everybody that
i'm a real vampire although you know
probably most people wouldn't believe
you they would just think it was a
shtick or whatever but he's like i'm
just gonna tell everybody and he's like
yeah and he's basically like come at me
bro yeah like to all the other vampires
you know come get me because you're all
like cowards for not coming out into
the out into public so that's so they
kind of addressed that in this one too
so like yeah i like that you brought up
that anne rice was probably i mean yeah
there's like a lot of vampire laura in
the books and stuff like traditional
vampire lore but
probably that was the closest analog
prior to the books coming out would have
been the black yellow movies
because that like you said showed the
vampire and i'm not saying that you know
the dracula movies and stuff didn't show
some of them showed uh you know dracula
as a more sympathetic figure uh or at
least like not not as monstrous as he
was in the book
but the blacula movies actually he was
kind of the main character and he was a
very sympathetic character because he
was an unwilling vampire yeah it wasn't
just that too it was also showed that
there was a dread that there was a
vampire culture yeah and vampires had a
culture you'd have to to survive
centuries
and and
and i guess maybe because
you know african-american culture is
basically an american subculture so you
got black people writing and they go you
know what [ __ ]
vampires would have a subculture too so
how what would that look like
and for some reason i guess maybe when
you come from a majority culture you
don't really think of it that way yeah
you think of it as well the vampire's
the other
who cares what they do yeah i think i
think that's what how they that was the
point of view they were just trying to
make a quick monster movie
they weren't really looking into it that
deep right but because but because their
experiences are different then it comes
out differently right right so i just
thought it was you know so
and not me making this up [ __ ] anne
rice said that those those movies were
her
real one of her primary inspirations
those two movies they're they're good
movies now
oh you want to get a good copies of them
when you watch them
uh
they've been remastered i got both of
them and they look great good fashion
good acting pretty good you know they
have a small they're a small budget
movie but they're fun
you know and they're not i mean by the
titles you would think they're like
super cheesy and stuff they're really
not they're actually like quite serious
they really shouldn't have been named
that
but people remember it yeah and the
second screen black yellow screen like i
said has a voodoo
angle to it too right which takes you to
new orleans and that's where anne rice
was from and they and then the whole
tricks about how a vampire will [ __ ]
turn somebody into a vampire just so
they could steal his house
yeah because why go through the trouble
of buying a house why go through the
trouble having to deal with a lawyer and
[ __ ] closing costs or [ __ ] having
your name on the record whatever house
you want just go turn that [ __ ] owner
that homeowner into a vampire and and he
needs you for protection now
because yeah
when you're a baby vampire you've got
like yeah
you don't have all the powers yet right
and he gives you any [ __ ] you have him
sign it all over to you then you kill
him and that's the kind of [ __ ] they
would do
and then just get another house
do it again somewhere else
yeah i mean that's how the wii was
turned into a vampire
because scott wanted his house yeah
and he just happened to be there yeah um
but yeah well what i was gonna say too
like a long time ago was that i kind of
feel like if i was a vampire if you're a
vampire you'd probably want to go like
target
shitty people you do like some dexter
[ __ ] yeah you know what i mean like go
after [ __ ] killers and that's yeah
see that's what i thought i thought he
just went up because like you said he
was kind of he was conflicted about it
not as conflicted as louis was obviously
but that was kind of i think let's stop
more he got kind of more into it as time
went on he would see girls he'd be into
you know what i mean would be tempted to
eat him you know what i mean and then
sometimes he usually he did eat him but
then sometimes he'd fight it off you
know and now i'm not gonna eat this one
he let her live and watch her
he i think he mentions that some of them
he
he watched him until they grew old
he kept going back checking on him yeah
just kind of because they got real
fascinated with certain people you know
just because you know because the way
they looked or the way they the way they
felt in their presence type of deal
they're they're
psychic yeah
yeah and they're [ __ ] uh they were
kind of in a certain ways uh
um nostalgic about things and uh
sentimental they're sentimental that's a
good way to put it real sentimental
but they'll kill you
yeah yeah
oracle asked me have i read the novel
fever dream civil war era vampires by
george rr martin i have not uh but i
will get around to it one of these days
i'm sure
um
it's interesting because i think
everybody like pretty much most people
know that anne rice wasn't you know when
they were doing interview with a vampire
in 1994 she wasn't a big fan when they
announced that tom cruise was gonna be
in it but then she later you know she
had the grace to come out and be like oh
i was wrong you know he actually did a
really good job um and it seemed but you
know what's weird about this one when
this one came out
she saw the finished movie like i think
before it came out and she's like oh
okay yeah that's pretty good um but then
i think that she kind of thought about
it again because like a year or two
later she was like oh never mind that
kind of sucked like i don't that's not
what she said but she was just kind of
like she she didn't think it was that
good at all i think like when she first
saw it maybe she was just kind of like
it's free on tubey
okay yeah you can watch it for free you
can watch for free on tubing uh it
doesn't it doesn't take away anything
but your time no
2.99 on um
amazon amazon prime
uh this copy looked a lot better than
than the copy that i remembered seeing
on dvd long time ago but you see it on
eight in hd on a good hd tv it looks a
lot better than i remembered it yeah i
don't know if they remastered it or what
it looked a lot better some of the cg
looks looks better
but
it's it's okay i mean the cj's okay i
like what you see like say an underworld
or something like that that's another
movie i didn't really like that i mean
it's just stock the cg is not and the
special effects are not why you watch
these movies anyway the books were like
soap operas
yeah you know
if they weren't action really um
but you know if you see movies like this
and you [ __ ] they spark your interest
then i would go read the books
go see you know interview with a vampire
the first one's better
well and honestly after seeing this one
yeah um i think that makes interview
with the vampire look even better even
better in retrospect yeah um which i
thought it was a masterpiece i know it's
like a backhanded kind of like
it's almost i thought interview the
vampire was a masterpiece when it came
out i knew it wasn't accurate but it
looked really good and the act i liked
the acting the storytelling i accepted
it there were differences in the book
but i said okay like that's it yeah but
i mean
you gotta do that sometimes because like
i said sometimes you know stuff that
works in a book doesn't work in a movie
you know sometimes it's in the book and
it looks ridiculous in a movie or you
know sometimes there's too many
characters you have to like winnow it
down and
focus more on one narrative and i think
they did a really good job of doing that
because interview with the vampire is an
enormous book and it's very very large
and very sprawling and i think they did
a good job
focusing on one narrative and keeping it
you know tight and efficient and i think
they did a really good job and all the
casting was good this one i really don't
even know
what the d what the idea was like why
did they think that they were actually
going to take two books
and chop most of it out like chop all
the historical stuff out like i said i
know it was low budget it's like we
can't afford to do half the [ __ ] [ __ ]
in ancient egypt i get that okay
um it's not a terrible idea i guess
just to do like the modern parts of the
story
but
i don't know i just
it just seemed so weird it seemed very
unfocused to me there were little
details going through both movies though
that kind of bothered me
even this is even an interview with the
vampire the first one which is really
good louis
was southern
he was from he's from louisiana and he
didn't have a southern accent at all
brad pitt is not the kind of actor you
can get in to [ __ ] have an accent
okay
and then by the time queen of the damned
is happening in this one lestat would
have been in the south for what 400
years
although he was sleeping some of that
time
but that [ __ ] sounded like he
was straight from the hockey motherland
and that's not how he's described in the
book
in the book he had a slight french
accent
in this movie it seemed like he was
trying to have a little bit of a french
accent yeah that actor's irish okay yeah
but he did seem to have but then when he
sang it was the dude from corn yeah
which does not sound like a french
accent just for no information a bunch
of stuff that
these
anne rice was from the south these are
these are southern characters these are
old south vampires and there's not even
a hint of it between endless style
although to be honest um i was kind of
reading an article about this the other
day
if you have an actor that's not
spot on with doing accents this is
better it's better just to not do it it
would be a lot more distracting
to have them doing an accent and you
know that's not what they talk like then
just have them use their regular voice
because then that would just kind of
fade into the background
um so i'm kind of a big fan if
i mean unless you have an actor that's
really really good at doing accurate in
accents that aren't going to be
distracting
and as long as it's not like some big
huge superstar and you know what their
voice really sounds like and that's
going to be distracting
i kind of feel like maybe they should
just stick with their regular voices
instead of trying to do instead of
trying to do an accent that they're
maybe not going to do that well yeah i
think it would have been better to find
guys that [ __ ] actually could do it
well i mean in a perfect world
if you were actually gonna do an
accurate book thing they're like well
let's get somebody that actually talks
like that
because there's millions of actors in
the world i'm sure you could find
somebody that looked and sounded the
part
instead of trying to make somebody talk
like they don't talk like i said unless
they could do it unless like some people
are really good at that louis would have
sounded like a damn southern aristocrat
from the 1700s and [ __ ] lestat would
have sounded just like a creole because
they were already french they were
french southern french people in louis
and louisiana you know he's with santa
cruz
which is you know
high-class cajun
yeah yeah oh well what are you going to
do i mean you added a lot more to the
movie though for me it would add a lot
more flavor
you'd be like oh okay
it kind of places them in a place in
time they're not so
well and that's kind of going back to
because like interview with the vampire
i mean those like that had tom cruise
and brad pitt they're enormous stars we
know what their voices sound like yeah i
think if they had just busted out trying
to do accents i don't think the movie
would have worked be like kenny reeves
trying to do it exit that's what i'm
saying that yeah it would be like
i love you key on it like yeah
but it'd be like keanu reeves in francis
ford coppola's dracula it's just so so
distracting yeah he should have just
talked well i don't know if they
honestly in that movie i kind of wish
they got like i love keanu but i think
that they should have got another actor
for that because you know because his
regular voice is so california yeah that
um that would have been distracting too
that didn't even exist in those days
that's what i'm saying so it's like i
really kind of wish they had just got a
british actor i mean that would have
been i mean there's zillions and
zillions of great british actors they
could have got somebody just get real
british people to play british people is
what i'm saying it's you know what i
mean um and british people can play
americans too because they seem to be
good at doing the american accent yeah
british people are better doing southern
accents than americans are doing
strangely just look at the walking dead
all right
dude had me fooled that dude had me
fooled
now you put him next to [ __ ] um uh oh
did you play merle what's his name uh
michael rook michael rooker
rooker's [ __ ] that's my homeboy there
like that's the way it sounds yeah
yeah that's the way it's uh dermott says
winona ryder's accent wasn't great
either yeah it hers wasn't great it was
it didn't stick out to me as much
but
honestly with winona i wish she had just
talked like she normally talks
um you know it would have been a lot
less distracting it's just too
distracting when you when you have
people that that don't nail the accent
or that are so famous you know what
their voice really sounds like and to me
that's just distracting because i know
that's not what they sound like so the
whole time i'm watching the movie going
i wonder if they're going to mess this
accent up and it's like i'm not paying
attention to the movie then you know
what i mean
um you know so
i'm just going to say but yeah so
i mean at least in this one uh the dude
did try to do like a little bit of a
french accent it wasn't fantastic but
you know it's at least sort of closer
to the actual character the only thing i
can
nix him on is that he did not seem
comfortable around women
well like i said he's where those girls
are coming on to him he just seemed very
uncomfortable
and if you read those books
no the stop was [ __ ] comfortable
around women he could [ __ ] slip right
in
and he he could put on an act and
he was just uh no well like i said i
think that might have been just because
in general he wasn't a real charismatic
presence right um
and honestly and this wasn't addressed
in the movie but i kind of feel like
lestat
he he really kind of had a thing i bel i
think in the books that he didn't really
like
killing innocent people
um
so it seemed a little out of character
to make him in the movie a rock star
that's like picks out two groupies right
each night to that he can eat i feel
like lestat of the book wouldn't have
done that i don't remember the in the
book doing that i don't think he did
that no that's that wasn't his he had
like an honor code he wouldn't have done
that even when even when um
even in the movie when when they were
when he was eating the octoroon girls in
in in new orleans
he's doing it to try to toughen up louis
but lestat knows these girls backstories
they had been [ __ ] poisoning and
murdering clients for [ __ ] years
remember that yeah
and and and
and he's like well we have to we you
know he was trying to get louie to kill
his first person and he wouldn't do it
and he goes well then i guess we have to
make them vampires then because they've
seen us yeah no no no and it was because
[ __ ] lestat was smart
when he got when he'd find a
cold-blooded killer there were only two
things you could do with them and that
was you either drank them you ate them
or you turned them into a vampire he was
deciding whether or not he was going to
turn those girls into vampires because
they would have made good vampires
yeah they were already killing people
and they had the look they were the
right age and that's explained in the
book but he didn't tell we lou he
couldn't read minds yeah he didn't he
was just a baby he was just trying to
toughen him up so he could survive as a
vampire yeah because he wasn't eating he
was drinking rats
that's right he really really did not
want to you would need him to eat a
person yeah
which well like i said you know you'd
kind of get that uh when you if you
returned against your will if you watch
interview with a vampire you as the
audience you're not giving the back
story that lestat knows that these two
girls are serial murderers
yeah
they're mad murderers no need for me too
says uh
i feel lestat was almost an anti-hero
yeah that's exactly what it was in the
books so he did even though he did like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but
he still had like i said a code of honor
yeah he had reasons for a lot of [ __ ]
and he had reasons for [ __ ] that he did
he what so so the fact that they made
him in this yeah he was arrogant and
[ __ ] like that which he is in this movie
but he wouldn't have just been like
plucking girls out of the thing and like
just bringing them backstage and eating
them he wouldn't have done that
he liked good people
yeah he thought they were he thought
they were uh rare
kind of a deal that they would
but he didn't necessarily protect him
but he'd protect him from other vampires
yeah
yeah so he did have like a moral code
yeah he wasn't just a monster yeah he
would admit to it though well yeah right
but yeah so
if you're interested to see this move
like i said i don't necessarily
recommend it especially if you're uh you
know if you like the books because this
it's not really so much of it was
changed or left out or whatever you
might be interested in the books
see interview with a vampire first yeah
because that's like way better yeah
that's a much better impression that's
closer to the way that the books are
yeah the the the vibe of that movie is a
lot closer to what the book is and you
can see this one afterwards if you want
it's fun it's a fun watch but the books
are much much better that's how i'm
gonna put it and to be honest if you see
this movie without having read the books
i'm not really entirely sure what if
you'll know what's going on because it
seems like a lot of the characters that
are introduced if you haven't read the
books you'll be like who the [ __ ] is
this and what do they have to do with
that person and what it's very very
disjointed
um
but you know i knew what was going on
because i'd read the books but if you
haven't you'll just be like what the who
cares what the [ __ ] who what what all
these people have to do with each other
you know what i'm saying yeah uh but you
know it's free on to be like i said if
you want to watch it um
so check it out if you've if you like it
if you hate it i don't really see a lot
of people that liked it to be honest
with you it's kind of i think on rotten
tomatoes i think it's got 17 percent
so i agree no need for me the the tom
cruise lestat i prefer better yeah yeah
and like i said i'm not usually a big
tom cruise fan so that's a big deal for
me to say that um and i wasn't happy
either when he got cast in ezra stop but
he did a really good job gotta say i
like tom cruise when he's on when he's
on he's on when he's not on he's not on
i mean he can crush it when he wants to
yeah and and uh
interview the vampire was
one of his top two or three movies he's
oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah um he brought it for
that role well because it it played the
character of the stop plays into his
natural charisma and cockiness yeah um
you know what i mean so he so that
really like gave the character a lot of
because that's a lot of what lestat was
like and for me tom if you're listening
bro
ethan hunt you nail it you nail it
especially the newer the newer
movies the newer mission impossible
movies are great
yeah that's what we saw in the theater
was really good
yeah i did i i liked that yeah quite a
lot
all right so i guess that'll wow we went
on for an hour about yeah i figured we
probably would we we liked it we had we
had feelings
about it honestly one of these days i'll
have to go back and reread all the
vampire chronicles when i have time yeah
when i get old i can't like get out of
chair anymore and i can sit there for
hours and hours but uh yeah so i guess
that'll
end up our discussion today r.i.p and
rice and we will be back again tomorrow
talking about another movie so thanks
everybody for dropping by and we'll see
you guys tomorrow